bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 une édition pour
revenir sur l'ensemble de l'actualité
locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de ce mercredi
7 mars la présence de terres agricoles
facteur d'attractivité pour les grandes
métropoles c'est ce que cherchait à
démontrer un séminaire qui se tenait ce
matin a dit le pr près de 200 personnes
présentes autour de deux tables rondes
élus exploitants chercheurs et
spécialistes venus de genève milan ou
encore montréal
il demande un accueil plus digne des
migrants dans le département et en
france une cinquantaine de personnes
s'est mobilisée ce mercredi matin devant
la préfecture des yvelines à versailles
une manifestation à l'appel du réseau
amis qui regroupe plusieurs
organisations associations et collectifs
des yvelines reportage à suivre
enfin les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient réunis hier en conseil
communautaire à l'ordre du jour le
rapport d'orientation budgétaire fixante
à la ligne pour 2018 un budget qui doit
être construit une nouvelle fois avec la
contrainte des baisses des dotations de
l'état
et puis à deux invités dans ce journal
également françoise perrier présidente
de l'association à delos apei 78
l'association a pour but de répondre aux
besoins et aux attentes des personnes
handicapées la deuxième invitée nous
recevons également un patrick dos un
directeur du réseau entreprendre
yvelines qui va à la rencontre ce soir
des étudiants de l'estaca c'est à suivre
près de 200 personnes ont assisté ce
mercredi un séminaire thématique les
territoires agréés urbain dans les
grandes métropoles un événement organisé
au domaine de grand'maisons à villepreux
au coeur de la plaine de versailles est
des échanges pour réfléchir sur
l'organisation et la gouvernance de ces
territoires proches de centres urbains
reportage de nicolas d'andré avoir
l'agriculture a porté de ville avec un
équilibre entre zones agricoles et zones
urbaines
c'est le principe des territoires agri
aubin la thématique d'un séminaire
organisé par l'association patrimoniale
de la plaine de versailles
je pense qu'il est indispensable
à l'heure actuelle dans notre société de
pouvoir maintenir des équilibres entre
et bien les urbains et les agriculteurs
au programme notamment une table ronde
sur les facteurs d'attractivité des
territoires agréés robin dans les
grandes métropoles avec des retours
d'expérience de montréal genève ou
encore milan du côté je né vois les
cultures sont maraîchères et viticole
l'agriculture milanaise
elle s'appuie sur les céréales et le riz
nos forces réside dans une profession
qui tient à garder un lien très fort
avec la terre qui veut pouvoir nourrir
la population
il y avait quand même des actions
publiques pour mettre en valeur la
filière
notamment la filière du riz qui est
produit localement transformer
localement est vendu en direct sur la
plaine de versailles l'association
patrimoniale créé en 2004 permet des
échanges entre trois groupes les élus
les agriculteurs et la société civile
le principe c'est que on vient
accompagner les projets par une bonne
confiance entre les élus et le monde
agricole
c'est dans ces conditions qu'une
douzaine de jeunes agriculteurs se sont
installés dans la plaine de versailles
sur ces trois dernières années dans
l'actualité également à versailles un
rassemblement organisé ce matin par le
réseau accueille des migrants en
yvelines un collectif d'une trentaine
d'organisations qui réclame un accueil
plus digne des migrants en france et
dans le département enjeux d'actualité
aussi avec le projet de loi asile et
immigration portée en ce moment par le
gouvernement nicolas kirillovitch et
quentin le frère créée il ya seulement
quelques semaines le réseau ami a mené
sa première opération devant la
préfecture des yvelines
la cinquantaine de personnes présentes a
réclamé un meilleur accueil des migrants
elle a exprimé aussi ses inquiétudes
quant à la politique menée par le
gouvernement sur la question migratoire
la france pays terre d'accueil cinquième
puissance du monde peut accueillir
dignement des migrants pas quelques
milliers mais bien 150 ou 200 mille
personnes sur 66 millions ça prouve
absolument aucun problème
d'autant plus que ces gens ces jeunes
ces femmes ces enfants nous apporte la
richesse de leurs cultures leurs
connaissances constitué de différentes
organisations associations et collectifs
le nouveau réseau à me soutient les
migrants dans leurs démarches juridiques
apporte aussi une aide matérielle
culturelles et sportives l'an passé cent
mille personnes ont demandé l'asile en
france pour faire passer leurs messages
plusieurs membres du réseau ont
rencontré directement le préfet des
yvelines ce qu'elle attend surtout c'est
que cette loi que le préfet ne soient
pas lésés cutter de des lois n'a pas
encore évalué la la
l'efficacité de la loi qui est actuel et
on est en train d'en fin d'en faire une
autre qui est encore pire que celle d'un
port le projet de loi asile et
immigration sera débattue courant avril
à l'assemblée nationale pour tenter de
convaincre les députés de la république
en marche yvelinois de voter contre les
membres du réseau ont envoyé une lettre
ouverte aux parlementaires versailles
qui abrite audiard des chantiers le
dernier guichets des yvelines d'achat de
billets grandes lignes il doit cesser
son activité cet été hier mardi à des
militants de la cgt cheminots de
versailles ont interpellé sur le sujet
valérie pécresse et alain à cracovie
on vous en parlait la présidente de la
région ile de france et le directeur
général de sfr sncf transilien était
venu inaugurer une consigne v-league au
les cheminots dénoncent une dégradation
du service public
alain à cracovie tx lui a confirmé la
fermeture du guichet à car les achats de
billets se font de plus en plus sur
internet transport toujours la presque
fin du chantier de la route
départementale à 30a plaisir
l'inauguration de cet axe de circulation
elle vient d'avoir lieu en présence des
élus locaux les travaux doivent répondre
à une problématique de circulation qui a
touché la ville est les précisions de
wilfrid richy patrick jacques de dixmude
et quentin le frère
trente mille véhicules par jour
empruntent cet axe de la route
départementale 30 à hauteur de plaisir
autant d'automobilistes qui devrait donc
être soulagés et passer moins de temps
dans les bouchons
après trois ans de travaux la deux fois
deux voies est ouverte le dossier a tout
de même été lancée voici vingt ans
c'est une des caractéristiques que je
crois aujourd'hui de la france
la multiplication des recours la
multiplication des des enquêtes
d
différentes phases administratives qui
sont inimaginables font que bien entendu
on a rallongé les délais de réalisation
et il faudrait j'espère que ce message
va être entendu c'est qu'il y ait moins
de recours quand on fait des
infrastructures ont fait pas pour
embêter les gens ont fait pour améliorer
la vie des gens
la patience aura payé le doublement de
la route sa compagne de murs acoustiques
sur plus de 2 km es22 souterrain c'est
la base même d'une femme qui les
fondamentaux pour que notre ville puisse
avoir des aspirations encore
supplémentaires dans un développement à
la fois commercial économique et un
cadre de vie parce que ça apporte
effectivement un grand confort à notre
deal
on aura beau lob de grillage ailleurs on
en a déjà beaucoup moins 87 millions
d'euros ont été investis 54 par la
région 33 par le département et les
travaux se poursuivent avec notamment à
l'automne une passerelle pour que
cyclistes et piétons puissent franchir
la nationale 12
une invitée m'a rejoint un plateau
françoise perrier bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes la présidente d'une association
bien implanté dans le département delos
api à 60,18 elle se fixe pour objectif
de répondre aux besoins et aux attentes
à des personnes handicapées on va en
parler dans un instant déjà un mot sur
l'histoire de cette association delos
apei 78 années en 2015 d'un regroupement
fait de trois associations qui était
implanté historiquement sur le
département la rencontre basé à
versailles et l'envol à mantes-la-jolie
elle crée donc que dans les années 60 la
troisième association c'est sésame
autisme ile-de-france qui elle a été
créée en 89
pourquoi fallait-il unir les forces
alors surtout il faut savoir que toutes
ces associations sont nées de la volonté
de parents il ya eu un très grand
mouvement il ya une cinquantaine
d'années à peu près de parents qui ont
voulu faire des choses pour leurs
enfants handicapés qui ont pris les
choses à bras le corps alors pourquoi
nous nous sommes réunis parce que
l'union fait la force c'est d'ailleurs
le nom des lots ça vient de la
mythologie grecque mais c'est l'union
fait la force et ça nous permet d'avoir
de faire face à la professionnalisation
du secteur parce qu'on peut plus faire
la bonne volonté ne suffit plus
maintenant il faut vraiment être
professionnel la complexité des règles
qui sont de plus en plus complexe et que
bah ça nous permettait vis-à-vis de nos
financeurs d'avoir un peu plus de poids
j'imagine aussi toucher plus de monde à
avoir une plus grand champ d'action
notamment sur del effectivement son
département ça nous a permis de nous on
a quand même beaucoup d'établissements
nous avons dit cet établissement qui
accueille 1100 personnes donc c'est
quand même pas rien avec 470 salariés et
il y en a à mantes versailles le but
clim et plaisir on en est on est on
couvre une partie du département et nous
essayons de fonctionner du mieux que
nous pouvons pour répondre aux besoins
et attentes des personnes accueillies
vous en avez parlé chaque membre du
conseil d'administration de cette
association a une histoire personnelle
un enfant qui est accueillie au sein
d'une structure de l'association
demandant notre conseil d'administration
nous avons des parents essentiellement
puisque nous sommes une association
parentale et nous y tenons beaucoup
mais cela ne nous empêche pas de
comprendre qu'il ya une
professionnalisation indispensable et
donc nous avons dû recruter du personnel
qui élit tout à fait professionnel est
ok ok c'est d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
rendre hommage parce qu'ils sont dans
une grande et dans des contraintes
budgétaires très très serré on ne peut
pas non plus faire des choses
extraordinaires et ils sont quand même
extrêmement dévoués par exemple quand il
s'est mis à neiger là c'est une
catastrophe parce que là c'est pour tout
le monde là exactement
eh bien eux sont restés sur place non là
je dois leur rendre hommage de façon
tout à fait officielle parce que c'était
quand même pas simple pour eux ni pour
nous vous les exemples et le 2000
personnes accueillir personnes
accueillies 770 professionnel est ce que
c'est assez il en faudrait beaucoup plus
évidemment et bien d'autres raisons
aujourd'hui nos besoins sont très
importants parce que nous avons à faire
face à une problématique qui n'a pas été
vu du tout parler politique et par
packard par personne fait c'est que nos
personnes handicapées maintenant
vieillissent il ya quelques années
quarante ans en arrière
elles n'avaient pas une espérance de vie
très importante donc maintenant ce n'est
plus le cas elles ont une espérance de
vie qui est à peu près la même que la
nôtre et rien n'a été prévu pour eux
donc le système est un petit peu bloqué
dans la mesure on peut on va pas les
mettre dehors de nos établissements sous
prétexte qu'ils sont vieux sérieuse mais
aujourd'hui les placements qui ont en
accueil de jour à l'ail et d'enfin
accueil de jour ou au foyer de vie ou
foyer enfin et c'est donc ya pas de
place pour eux résultat ça bloque les
places
dans les autres établissements qui ont
le même bloc les places dans un autre
établissement est à l'autre bout de la
chaîne c'est à dire pour les jeunes ce
qui commencerait à rentrer dans un
système professionnel de ce type là est
bien ya pas de place donc c'est un
problème de place dans des contraintes
budgétaires que vous connaissez puisque
de toute façon il ya de moins en moins
d'argent et donc c'est compliqué or une
valeur forte pour l'association c'est de
considérer la personne handicapée dans
dans toute son humanité
c'est une notion qu'on a tendance à
oublier aujourd'hui alors n'exagérons
pas il ya eu d'énormes progrès qui ont
été faits mais il demeure pas moins que
ça reste difficile pour une personne
handicapée de trouver sa place dans le
monde actuel donc il faut laisser nous
nous notre notre but c'est de les aider
justement à s'insérer dans le milieu
professionnel alors certains peuvent
travailler dans des entreprises normales
dans des entreprises adaptées d'autres
dans des sens dans des faux des esat
oui vous avez d'ailleurs fait un
remarquable reportage très récemment sur
seat les attié je précise établissement
et service d'aidé par le travail voilà
tu sors nous utilisons beaucoup dans le
monde du médico social des acronymes bon
mais c'est ça et en fait nous avons donc
17 établissements donc à lézat de faire
deux esat même on arrange r1 pour
l'orientation 4 pour le secteur enfance
4 pour le secteur du travail adapté
trois pour l'accompagnement social et 5
pour l'hébergement
d'accord nous ça c'est un ensemble très
important de dix sept établissements sur
les yvelines dont il recoupe plusieurs
secteurs vous l'avez absolument envoyer
l'orientation l'enfant ce travail
l'hébergement l'accompagnement social
voilà alors pour les esat notamment on
peut presser il y en a un qui est
implantée à but que l'autre à mantes la
ville a directement 2 2 est atteint un
bus qui invente la jolie ça doit être la
jolie plutôt que la ville et qui sont
des endroits où les personnes
travaillent mais adam 1 dans un contexte
qui leur est favorable c'est à dire de
façon adaptée avec des post adaptés etc
et où la problématique de la du
rendement n'est pas n'est pas la même
que dans une entreprise normale bien
entendu alors aujourd'hui vous en avez
aussi parlé les défis pour pour
l'association notamment les personnes
vieillissantes
notre problème numéro un c'est la
problématique numéro en numéro 1 parce
que là vraiment on va on va finir par
coincer totalement le système et ça va
devenir très compliqué et l'autre pro
matic que nous avons c'est de recruter
du personnel parce que c'est un métier
extrêmement difficile qui n'est pas très
bien payé malheureusement et du coup
c'était vraiment difficile de trouver
des personnes qui sont tout à fait aptes
à faire ce type de travail
donc là il ya tout un travail de
formation de qui doit être fait et qui
est aussi une de nos problématiques et
dans 16 des 17 établissements qu'est ce
qu'elles vont faire ces personnes alors
vous avez des éducateurs vous avez des
amp c'est à dire les aides
médico-psychologiques vous avez des des
personnes qui s'occupent tout simplement
de la vie courante c'est à dire le enfin
l'entretien etc
vous avez des moniteurs dans l'est dans
les esat vous avez toutes sortes de
personnes qui ont des qualifications
différentes pour des pour des rôles
différents mais qui sont tous
complémentaires
un dernier mot peut-être il nous reste
une minute environ une actualité de
l'association peut-être à partager alors
pas d'actualité vraiment maintenant mais
nous nous continuons à essayer de faire
en sorte que les personnes que nous
comme nous que nous accueillons soit le
mieux possible dans l'endroit où elles
sont et le plus insérés dans la société
est ce qu'on a eu ce qu'on apprécie
beaucoup c'est justement qu'ils puissent
être connue parce que le handicap fait
toujours peur donc plus ils sont connus
- on a peur et mieux ils sont intégrés
merci françois périer d'avoir est avec
nous je suis un prix présidente de
l'association a pas delos api 78,1 qui
se fixe pour objectif je rappelle de
répondre aux besoins et aux attentes des
personnes handicapées pour plus
d'informations sur cette association je
vous invite à aller sur le site internet
et vous pouvez également revoir un pour
avoir plus de précisions notamment sur
le travail dans les actes de but que
vous pouvez revoir un sou reportage sur
notre site internet merci d'avoir été
avec nous séance du conseil
communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines les élus se réunissent et hier
mardi notamment pour l'europe c'est le
rapport d'orientation budgétaire qui
fixe les grandes lignes pour 2018 un
budget qui s'annonce contraint les
détails avec ce sujet d'aurélien 11 donc
quelques semaines
saint-quentin-en-yvelines devra voter le
budget 2010 8 mai avant la présentation
du rapport d'orientation budgétaire est
une étape obligatoire
il permet aux élus de prendre
connaissance des contraintes financières
de l'agglomération première révélation
une baisse
la dotation globale de fonctionnement de
35 millions d'euros depuis 2014
si on projet jusque 2020 ce sera 50
millions et si on va jusqu'à des
projections de 2023 on peut aller
jusqu'à près de 100 millions donc quelle
est la structure publique ou
intercommunal chi chi qui peut résister
à ça c'est quand même ces oran dans une
phase comme très difficile pour cette
année 2010 8 il manque 13 millions
d'euros pour boucler le budget parmi les
pistes évoquées une mutation
institutionnelle
la réorganisation des services ou encore
une révision de la politique fiscale
moi je m'interdis rien mais c'est pas ce
serait pas ce serait pas un bon choix on
n'a jamais augmenté les impôts depuis
que nous sommes à la tête de cette
interco franchement c'est pas c'est pas
un choix c'est plutôt nous le dv connaît
le développement économique faire des
économies aussi restreinte peut-être des
investissements bien sûr un peu plus
serré tous les budgets
c'est plus se dire que cela qu'on se
dirige on va regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention la question des services à
la population à haut niveau de service
dans cette agglomération et on tient ce
que ça soit maintenue et que d'autres
projets d'autres sujets plus en plus
annexes ne soit pas privilégiée donc on
revenir aux fondamentaux de ce à quoi
doit servir l'agglomération c'est à dire
rendre des services aux habitants de 50
ans
prochaine étape pour les douze communes
qui composent saint quentin en yvelines
se réunir autour de la table pour faire
des choix
trois rendez vous sont programmés avant
le vote du budget en avril à saint
quentin en yvelines est implanté vous le
savez sans doute l'un des campus de
l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs
spécialisés dans les secteurs de
l'aéronautique de l'automobile du
spatial et du ferroviaire l'école qui
reçoit ce soir une centaine de chefs
d'entreprise pour des ateliers de
networking des patrons représentant le
réseau entreprendre yvelines justement
avec mon plateau le directeur ce réseau
patrick dos un bon soir cela donc
directeur du réseau entreprendre
yvelines alors vous serez aux côtés
notamment du directoire de l'estaca ce
soir pour cet événement on va parler
dans un instant déjà quelques mots sur
le réseau entreprendre yvelines qui
avait telles sont ses missions le réseau
entreprendre yvelines ce qu'elle me
partout en france est un réseau de chefs
d'entreprises qui accompagnent les
créateurs des créateurs de pme dès
l'instant où ils vont prévoir la
création d'un minimum de 5 à 10 emplois
gras et deux à trois ans d'accord et
donc réseau entreprendre yvelines
accompagne par ses membres chefs
d'entreprise en activité accompagne les
créateurs de façon strictement bénévole
et sans aucune prise d'intérêt cet
accompagnement c'est à la fois un
accompagnement financier en octroyant
des prêts d'honneur vous porteurs de
projets et puis c'est surtout
l'accompagnement par un nous membres
chefs d'entreprise en activité qui
pendant deux ou trois ans vingt deux
vases en structure et rencontrer nos
porteurs de projets une fois par mois
pour faire le pont et enfin on réunit
les promotions d'une lauréat d'une
promotion annuelle une fois par mois
pour leur permettre d'échanger des des
expériences des bonnes pratiques et des
bonnes adresses
on vous l'avait dit le réseau
entreprendre c'est au niveau national 14
mille chefs d'entreprise dans les
yvelines c'est une centaine de membres
c'est son nom dans les yvelines on a un
peu plus d'une centaine de membres
on accompagne chaque année une vingtaine
de porteurs de projets nouveaux
d'ailleurs l'année 2018 s'annonce très
très favorable et stable
on a aujourd'hui un bon nom d'un grand
nombre de projets et donc on a une
centaine de une centaine de membres qui
sont à la fois des patrons de pme à la
fois des dirigeantes gros ou des
professions libérales pour 85% d'entre
eux en activité et c'est bien fait c'est
un accompagnement de patrons
d'entreprises en activité qui est qui
est un apport très riche pour pour les
porteurs de projets c'est quelque chose
de primordial justement le fait que ces
chefs d'entreprise qui ont accompagné ce
soit en exercice amène le côté
expérience qui est non négligeable
ben voilà les entrepreneurs qui sont qui
sont nos membres et qui vont donc
accompagner les nouveaux entrepreneurs
que son no no no
nos jeunes créateurs qui sont jeunes ou
sans moins jeunes on pourra en dire un
petit mot tout à l'heure et bien
évidemment cette le fait d'avoir un
petit peu de bouteille d'avoir
l'expérience devoir être en activité
dirigée sur le même une entreprise et un
apport tout à fait considérable pour les
porteurs de projets et les jeunes
entrepreneurs
la dernière chose avant d'en venir à ce
soir cet accompagnement se fait c'est
important de le préciser avant la
création pendant et après ça veut dire
que l'entrepreneur n'est pas lâcher si
le cuir dans la nature une fois qu'il a
créé son entreprise absolument dorgba
une un parcours de validation et
d'accompagnement en amont avant dans la
création du projet et puis cet
accompagnement encore une fois les
structures et à travers un entretien
mensuel pendant une durée d'un minimum
de 2 à 3 ans donc ce le portable projets
d'entrepreneurs nouveau se trouve
effectivement accompagné de façon
structurée pendant une période de deux à
trois ans alors ce soir vous serez aux
côtés d'une centaine d'entrepreneurs
pour ses ateliers networking à l'estaca
là on est typiquement dans vos missions
ces deux rencontres et finalement les
futurs entrepreneurs ceux qui seront les
créateurs d'emplois de demain finalement
absolument alors en a eu l'occasion de
rencontrer des dirigeants de l'estac a
et vous savez que dans dans toutes les
écoles dans la plupart des écoles
qu'elles soient de commerce ou
d'ingénieur il y a une une main majeur
entrepreneuriat qui se met en place pour
tous les étudiants
vous avez comme sur un grand nombre de
nos étudiants d'aujourd'hui n'ont plus
le souhait au sortir de l'école de
trouver un job dans un grand groupe mais
au contraire de monter une start up est
donc une des préoccupations des
dirigeants de l'estac a cité de mettre
en place une
une mesure d'une orientation
entrepreneuriale pour leurs étudiants et
donc nous avons été amenés à traiter à
mettre en place un partenariat avec
l'estac a à la fois pour insuffler un
peu de d'esprit entrepreneurial auprès
d'eux de leurs étudiants qui sont
motivés par cette démarche
et puis à la fois pour accompagner de
façon privilégiée
un certain nombre d'étudiants en cours
d'étude ou en sortie de sortie de
l'école qui ont des projets et qui
souhaitent se lancer dans une démarche
entrepreneuriale atelier networking donc
ce soir le networking c'est le fait de
se constituer un réseau de relations et
de savoir dans le monde de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui se constitue un réseau on ne
peut pas faire sans pour réussir ma vie
active mans c'est quand même beaucoup
mieux d'avoir l'opportunité de
rencontrer des gens d'horizons très
différents à la fois des dirigeants
d'entreprise à la fois des des
financeurs des banquiers puis à la fois
des jeunes créateurs qui ont déjà plongé
ou qui sont en train de de mettre en
place leur projet et donc c'est la
logique de ces rencontres strictement
conviviale qui a pour objectif de
permettre aux gens de d'échanger de se
rencontrer
il reste quinze secondes qu'est ce qui
va se passer ce soir concrètement
comment ça va se dérouler cette soirée
va se passer une soirée de pure
convivialité qui va permettre à la fois
aux étudiants aux jeunes anciens et aux
entrepreneurs que nous accompagnons et
puis à nos membres
ben de partage et de se rencontrer et
puis pourquoi pas d'échanger des cartes
de visite ou d'échanger des contacts de
façon à accélérer le développement des
projets merci patrick gauvin d'avoir est
avec nous merci à vous directeur du
réseau entreprendre des vinées pour plus
d'information 1 sur l'association rendez
vous au site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et des ateliers
collectifs et accompagnement sur mesure
pour renforcer sa présence à
l'international c'est ce que propose la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles yvelines avec le dispositif
booster paris-saclay export il a été
présenté hier au ski cuba guyancourt
à partir du mois d'avril 16 entreprises
yvelines de l'essonne vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ce programme pendant 18
mois propos recueillis par
au rayon ces entreprises doivent être
exportatrice ou avoir un fort projet
développement à l'export parce que
l'objectif c'est partager les
expériences donc on vient pas seulement
pour prendre on vient dans ce groupe
pour donner partager les bons tuyaux les
bons contacts les bonnes adresses
les bonnes façons de faire lorsqu'on
veut se développer à l'international
le principe aussi de ces groupes c'est
qu'il n'y a que des entreprises multi
sectorielle je peux pas avoir deux
entreprises du même secteur d'activité
parce qu'on dévoile les stratégies les
visions d'entreprise à trois ou cinq ans
et donc on y voit le forcément des
choses à caractère confidentiel
dans ce groupe il faut par des
concurrents l'intérieur du groupe un
événement insolite pour refermer ce
journal direction vélizy villacoublay où
se déroulait le week-end dernier les
championnats de france de bras de fer
une discipline qui compte une
soixantaine de licenciés en ile de
france et vous allez le voir avec ce
sujet de michael et me doro et nicolas
dendre y avoir de gros bras ne suffit
pas regardez mes poignets
gbagbo tu t'adresses à la table
prouver que le bras de fer est un vrai
sport l'objectif de ce quatrième
championnat de france organisé ce samedi
3 mars dans la commune de vélizy
villacoublay
pour cela deux arbitres assistent au
match et font appliquer des règles
codifiées par les américains au siècle
dernier
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif pas du bras de fer de
comptoir pour vos poignets soit bien
droit québec est ton soit en fait je me
dis l'épaule bien en face
que vous soyez dans l'axé médian de la
table pour que les règles de ce sport
soit entièrement respectée les arbitres
n'hésite pas à lier les participants
tout simplement parce qu'elle en fait ya
eu un lâcher de l'enfant n'ont pas
réussi à terminer le combat entre
emprise
sur la table la testostérone et autour
du biceps ne font pas tout chaque ferry
se doit s'échauffer plusieurs minutes
avant son passage et surtout avoir une
stratégie pour emporter la victoire
l'intérieur ça veut dire en fait on
passe intérieure on reste groupé et en
tire comme ça et extérieur en utilise la
rotation jugé plus comme ça la force est
au service de la technique et non la
force qui remplace la technique vous
avez des gens qui pour d'autres
disciplines sont des gens très puissants
mais quand vous les mettez sur l'étape
de braqueurs ils ont un petit niveau de
résistance mais après ils n'ont pas la
télé ils sont un peu perdus cet
événement permettra peut-être d'attirer
de nouveaux licenciés pour ce sport
encore confidentiel qui compte seulement
200 pratiquants france et une trentaine
dans les yvelines
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi les reportages et le
replay sont à consulter sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
soixante dix huit la suite de vos
programmes vous avez notamment rendez
vous ce soir avec le 7-8 culture comme
tous les mercredis présentée par mélanie
poquet excellente soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]